Miami Wow
so happy to be here with you guys you
know Miami is like my second home it's
my alma mater I went to University of
Miami actually believe it or not so
there's anything you people hear and
it's funny because I actually double
majored in film and philosophy which at
the time most people looked at me like I
was crazy because it's just like who
combines film and philosophy what kind
of practical applications does that have
in the world but thankfully my mother
Linda who is an educator and has been
for 40 years and an artist she said you
know do what you love follow your bliss
follow your passion all that jazz you
know which one you put it into practice
you actually realize this really good
advice so my whole career has been this
kind of improvised sort of dance where
I've tried to combine my first loves
which are you know filmmaking making
content making media that epiphan eise's
people and of course talking about ideas
that agitate the sleep of mankind you
know so the key thing is can we create
content that can Electrify Electrify us
that can awaken us that can transform us
that can agitate that fire in the belly
in directed towards positive
transformation and positive change and
this is where it all starts for me you
know like people asking me what is what
is the origin story where does the
inspiration for these videos come from
what compels you to get in front of the
camera and get out of your head and out
of your mind and sort of tap into that
creative flow so to speak and it really
all began with a book that my
other had on her shelf in venezuela
among many books that i would that i
would open up and browse but this
particular book by Ernest Becker it was
a Pulitzer Prize winning book written
1974 called the denial of death and the
denial of death was a book that
basically distilled the human condition
right it got to the the worm at the core
the source of our anxiety the source of
our existential angst the source of our
dread and the key idea here is that
human beings are unique in the animal
kingdom because we are aware that we are
mortal right human beings cannot live
with a continuous belief in something
indestructible within himself yet we are
aware that we are mortal bees I think it
was a guy called Sheldon Solomon who
said to have emerged from nothing to
have a name a consciousness of self deep
inner feeling an excruciating inner
yearning for life and self-expression
and yet with all this yet to die
human beings find themselves in quite
the predicament we have the mental
capacity to ponder the infinite
seemingly capable of anything yet we're
housed in heart-pumping Brett gasping
decaying bodies so we are simultaneously
gods and worms this is the human
condition the explicit awareness that
you're a breathing piece of defecating
meat destined to die and ultimately no
more significant than the lizard or a
potato is not especially uplifting and
not to start off things with an
existential bummer but this is the worm
at the core and when I read this book it
shook me because it seemed to give voice
to that anxiety it seemed to give voice
to that fear of the abyss and so what do
we do right how do we respond to the
human
conundrum so Ernest Becker basically in
his book chronicled three solutions they
called them the three solutions to the
problem of death
and they make a whole lot of sense the
first solution to the problem of death
the way that we move beyond the
paralysis trembling before the Kosmos
the first solution of the problem of
death is the religious solution the
religious Ellucian provides a narrative
that consoles us right there is God
there is heaven there is an afterlife
there is an eternal soul you follow the
rules of this virtual reality game and
you will live forever in the kingdom of
God it's a great abstract symbolic
solution if you invest yourself fully in
it it seems to LA the existential dread
but not all of us are satiated by these
kinds of opiates those of us that seek
out ask more questions those of us that
refuse easy answers have eclipsed the
capacity of the religious solution of
the problem of death to solve our
anxiety and so if religion doesn't do it
for us anymore for some of us any more
than what does right what Wells that
faint disquiet the second solution to
the problem of death I imagine many of
you are very familiar with it is they
romantic solution to the problem of
death and this one made a lot of sense
right this is when we deify our lovers
she's like the wind
she's my salvation she is the Sun it's
every pop song lyric that's ever been
written it's summer love right you turn
a person into a god and you are absolved
of your mortal coil by rubbing up
against perfection itself it works
for a minute
turn in the Eternity nothing is real
that is not eternal own Road negated
there when I'm oh no in tragic sense of
life when in love we enter this holy
halo and for that moment for that
honeymoon phase we are commingling with
each other naked ly as gods outside of
time temporarily moving out of the
people mover that's carrying everyone
else towards death so we are freed from
the tyranny of time and we enter a pop
song with someone else and believe me
that is a wonderful high the promise of
forever with another person quells the
panic it really does you get the entire
romantic comedy industry can testify to
the facts I mean you watch a movie like
Love Actually or Vanilla Sky or
breakfast at tiffany's you listen to the
melodies of the movies that we love and
you get the goosebumps and you feel like
I am saved as long as I'm inside this
melody inside this scene death cannot
touch me time cannot kill me but what
happens no relationship can bear the
burden of godhood eventually our gods
reveal their clay feet those clay feet
mirror our own entropic processes back
to us the innovate inevitability of
Love's aging is intolerable to those of
us who have invested ourselves
completely in the idea of romantic love
as salvation love is ultimately a
religious problem and in the end as much
as I keep going back like a hamster
going back to the drug it will not
satiate us so what is the third solution
to the problem of death and I ping-pong
between number two and number three by
the way the third solution to the
problem of death is the creative
solution to the problem
of death and this is where we have truly
excelled all right the creative solution
to the problem of death is to respond to
this anxiety with creativity it's to
respond to this anxiety with a
willingness to overcome boundaries and
transcend our limitations that is the
human story that is human imagination
that is creativity that is our capacity
to create virtual models in our heads
combined with our modest-looking thumbs
sufficient to create a secondary force
of evolution called technology that will
continue until the entire universe is at
our fingertips that's what put airplanes
in the sky that's what creates devices
made of plastic and metal that allow us
to share our thoughts across time and
space that's what has allowed us to
collapse the limitations of geography
that's what puts a man on the moon
that's what allows us to hear a song and
turn on sound hound and figure out what
the name of the song and download it
immediately and be able to reproduce it
that's what allows me to electrify my
thoughts with a microphone and spread it
to all of you that's what it allows
social media that's what it allows
science that's what allows biotechnology
that's what allows vaccinations that's
what allows the car transportation that
brought you here I mean it is our
creativity that has doubled the human
lifespan it is our creativity that
engenders technological miracles that
astound on a daily basis today a hundred
thousand aircraft took off and landed
with perfect precision machines with a
million moving parts that fly us across
the sky with more safety than any other
form of transportation Ernest Becker
says that both the neurotic and the
artist bite off more than they can chew
they're both hypersensitive and opined
that both overwhelmed by the world but
the difference is that the neurotic is
precisely the one who cannot create and
so he chokes on his intro versions
whereas the artist he takes in the world
he's overwhelmed by it but he turns it
into an act
of work project right he turns it into a
challenge to be seized
I remember the psychologist Jordan
Peterson once said that human beings
become activated when they have a noble
aim right when they have a goal right at
the end of the rainbow that they're
moving towards they organize their lives
in a way that they can move towards that
noble aim never quite attaining it
because then the game is over all right
but always moving slowly towards it it
infuses our lives with meaning it
energizes us to come up with creative
ways to attain our goals this is what I
think has sustained humanity right human
beings exist in a way at the interplay
between the finite and the infinite set
tall story and it is in this interplay
in which we can express our creativity
and we can engender and create things
seemingly that are not subject to
entropy decay and death we create
transcendent art right and why why do we
got at art you know I remembered readers
and also was saying he says because the
transcendent shines through the mad at
the masses the partially articulated
form right through art the divine beams
forth and this makes a lot of sense
whether it's our art our technology and
our creativity it is probably the
healthiest response to the human Kanaan
dirham so I think this stuff is really
interesting because I think talking
about our situation is a sort of an
honest dialogue with ourselves that we
need to have on a regular basis rather
than sweeping it under the rug right and
this is what compels me to make these
videos to start these conversations to
kind of start this off I want to load up
the first video number one which kind of
sums up the human condition as I see it
so let's play the first video
all is temporary even our greatest
ecstasy's are tinged by a bit of
darkness this moment will pass this
moment will end
I may have lost her I may have lost this
moment but now I have this piece of
content that I can always go back to to
remind me of the intensity of that I
will not just like forget this I will
not forget you
for me a life well-lived is a life that
is not about victories or losses but
about a continuous process of growth a
continuous process of adventure
curiosity and awe one in which you don't
go quietly into that good night at the
end of the race but instead you rage and
rage and rage against the dying of the
light as Alan Harrington said we must
never forget we are cosmic
revolutionaries not Stooges conscripted
to advance a natural order that kills
everyone
having invented the gods
we can turn into them
kind of sets thanks it kind of sets up
the existential bummer there's kind of a
unique awareness that even our greatest
ecstasy's are tinged by a bit of sadness
you know I used to feel that when I was
a little kid I'd go to the toy store
usually in Miami and I'd walk in and I'd
get anxiety over the fact that I'd have
to walk out after a finite amount of
time just tell my mom can I stay in the
toy store forever time it was just it
was aware of sort of the tyranny of
transience ephemerality haunted my
dreams pause thanks and so this this was
something I sort of had to deal with as
a child you know I remember asking my
parents well does that mean you guys are
gonna get old one day does that mean I'm
gonna lose you guys one day I mean I
just I found it in tolerable and I guess
I guess I mean you've seen it in my
videos that I've sort of sought out s
opiates answers intellectual neuro
storms right of intense intellectual
pleasure ideas that would energize me
solutions to our situations I became a
polymath I read every every book I
stumbled upon every idea you know and of
course I went through a materialist
phase I think the consumer society that
we live in today while producing amazing
goods and services no doubt fails to
address the fact that you can't buy your
way out of existential despair
you know it's proven actually that the
more you buy the emptier you feel
ironically and so we've created this
kind of multi trillion-dollar economy to
sell ourselves things to temporarily
absolve us of our dread knowing full
well that that's a finite thing that
hedonic adaptation which is part of our
neural chemistry will eventually kick in
that anything that's always around is
invisible that things stop giving us
pleasure after repeated exposure so
things don't work buying things won't
fix it it'll make our lives maybe more
comfortable and more comfortable bed to
sleep in a beautiful car whatever it may
be but it doesn't solve the problem of
mental health it doesn't solve the
problem of happiness and we see the
evidence in the fact that we live in the
most wealthy Society in the history of
the world
people have more of what they need than
any other time in human history violence
across the planet is down we've never
lived in such an abundant world and yet
the incidences of anxiety and depression
are epidemic I read a statistic from the
United Nations that said 800,000 people
a year now are committing suicide that
is a larger amount of people than die
from armed conflicts and natural
disasters combined so you know you're
worried about like hurricanes and people
dying you know worried about armed
conflict horrible things the biggest
danger is suicide to yourself more
people kill themselves per year 800,000
then die from armed conflicts and
natural disasters combined that's
according to the United Nations so holy
[ __ ] like what is going on all right so
to try to answer this both for my own
incessant ruminations but also to
address something that has become
epidemic and systemic in the world it
was like okay well let's like figure
this out so some psychologists are now
saying of course that we get more
satisfaction from experiences than from
things you know don't buy you know buy
experiences not things experiences not
things and so that's kind of cool okay
so I thought okay first let's do and
this is kind of like the story arc of my
of my remarks today let's start out with
a video that establishes why we are so
unhappy my own attempt to figure this
out and and then we'll go through
because there is good news at the end of
the tunnel then we'll go through some of
the solutions that I have found to
render our lives
holy acts indeed so next video please
one of the maladies of the modern age is
that even though collectively we have
more than we've ever dreamed possible
we remain perpetually dissatisfied it's
almost like we are wired never to be
content and it seems to be the case I
mean it's been written that we are
insatiable wanting machines designed to
desire and so in some ways that has made
us reach out and transcend boundaries we
didn't stay in the caves we haven't
stayed on the planets we went to the
moon we criss cross the skies we extend
and we transcend but on the other hand
that exploratory itch that genetic pull
that makes us tread forth always in
search of the insatiable deliciousness
of the new the wholly other the
mysterium tremendum if I see now some of
the unfamiliar also makes quotidian
day-to-day life kind of banal again it's
kind of sad because the very same
quality that makes us these majestic
creatures is soar above the heavens and
transcend their boundaries has made us
perpetually dissatisfied neurotic beings
living in urban centers drowning and
consumption and an over capitalist
bloated system that can no longer
satiate as always finding something else
until we're like you know overwhelmed
and overweight
you know immobilized by how spoiled
we've become and yet we enjoy very
little of it so what we do how do we
find a way leverage and combine and we
can figure this the tension of this
situation you know that we always want
more has made us great but that we
always want more also makes us kind of
miserable
I hadn't resolved that when I shot that
video but you can feel the you can feel
the suffering you know you can feel the
frustration and you know it seems
self-evident but there was like okay
things aren't cutting it you know we are
miserable a lot of the time and yet we
have so much so what gives
so maybe the solution is actually mental
to store the contents of consciousness
to learn to mediate internal mental
states and so this is how I discovered
flow so there's an organization called
the flow Genome Project to take notes of
this they just yes they just published a
book recently called stealing fire which
of course references the Promethean
spirit of stealing fire from the gods
and figuring out how to hack ourselves
and upgrade our cognitive apparatus and
basically bliss ourselves out the key
idea being that we can transform ourself
systems which are like leaky buckets
they're like Hollanders according to
Jamie Weil and Steven Kotler and if we
could figure out a hack those calendars
those leaky buckets and transform them
let's say into chalices then maybe we
could render ourselves whole and then
render ourselves wholly and just this
like oh my god like this is when I start
to get really excited because oh [ __ ]
we can figure this out so flow is a
state of consciousness in which you feel
your best and you perform your best it's
that simple so it's the jazz musician
in the pocket it's the basketball player
when he's in the endzone right he's in
the zone and he's achieving the
impossible right
it's the snowboarder it's the surfer
catching that perfect wave right like
you've all probably had flow at some
point in your life maybe at work one day
everything is syncing up everything is
flowing effort everything is effortless
and in the school of positive psychology
they refer to these as states north of
happy you know like there's just nothing
better than flow and the reason why is
counter-intuitive because you're not all
there when you're in flow you're beyond
yourself you're beside yourself you're
in spite of yourself the inner critic
the monkey my into the inner Woody Allen
the chatter that never stops is finally
quieted right so there's an acronym to
describe what happens when you're in a
flow state the acronym is stir
selflessness your sense of self vanishes
the doer and the seer merge right
experiencing self and the remembering
self merge so you're not there anymore
right your sense of self disappears it's
like you're you're so in the moment that
all self-consciousness dissipates so the
inner critic the inner chatter the
rambling voice the rumination that stuff
that becomes like an overdrive with
people who are anxious or depressed
excessive rumination is a characteristic
of that completely disappears hallelujah
right the grace of the moment so there's
a sense of again selflessness austere
selflessness then there's timelessness
you're free from the tyranny of time
you're in the forever box they call it
there's a multi-billion dollar industry
of mindfulness Reena teach us how to
come back into the nap and again look
I'm not criticizing the human capacity
to think about the future okay that's
that's good it protects us with plan
ahead we build things we collaborate
like thinking about the future still
good it's when we're only and always
worried
about it that we fail to come back into
the grace of the here-and-now which is
pretty [ __ ] amazing when we're in it
so selflessness timelessness
effortlessness when you're in flow
it doesn't feel difficult the surfer who
achieves the impossible on the wave when
he's in flow is not struggling he
doesn't feel the difficulty he doesn't
feel the labor he doesn't feel the
fatigue he's in the zone when the jazz
musician is improvising insane melodies
in real time perceiving and creating at
the same time doesn't feel like he's
putting a lot of effort into it it's
like it's like something comes through
you but not from you and though it is
with you it belongs not to you
paraphrase Khalil Gibran so that
effortlessness
and finally richness information
richness you feel like you're
downloading you have access to more
information because when you're in flow
you get a boost of dopamine dopamine
increases pattern recognition and
increases lateral thinking and increases
associational thinking and it heightens
your perception of the moment but fluid
and dopamine can be triggered by novel
experiences and by challenges so the
attendees tend to be the flow triggers
novel experiences certain kinds of
challenges sweet spots right Goldilocks
not too hot not too cold like just
enough of a challenge that engages the
here and now not too much that
overwhelms you so there are all these
flow triggers and they map them out at
the flow Genome Project I definitely
recommend that you guys check them out
but as it turns out when we're in flow
again we feel our best and we're
blissed-out we're in the moment we're
free of the monkey mind time fails to
exist we live forever now so it ticks
all the boxes of the human Kanaan dirham
but finally our performance levels go
through the roof that's why companies
like Google are working with people like
the flow Genome Project guys figuring
out how to reverse engineer and create
flow triggers in the office how do we
make officers more creative I don't we
use colors on the walls the trigger flow
how do we use lighting how do we use
architecture right there's this whole
school thought ontological design
we use design to infuse internal states
as what we design designs us in return
this is all doable they've mapped the
psychological impact of built
environments there was an article in New
York magazine called the psychological
impact of boring buildings and it was
all about how bad design creases
cortisol can cause boredom which turns
to depression which causes distress
which is an inflammatory agent and so on
and so forth but the inverse is also
true right just like trauma can cause
PTSD a mystical experience is like
inverse PTSD can cure you of the trauma
so you can apply these insights of flow
to create environments both at home and
at work and for recreational purposes
that trigger flow and the best part is
that there's these exponential advances
happening in psychology technology
neurobiology and pharmacology these are
called the four forces of ecstasy
psychology technology neurobiology and
pharmacology so psychology is just
knowing these insights knowing these
triggers having this insights into human
condition how we respond to certain
situations spaces people so on and so
forth technology of course would be you
know music ecstatic dance an airplane
that takes you to an amazing place I
mean all these things neurobiology
pharmacology of course is drugs right
which is fine in certain contexts
there's a lot of advances happening
right now in using the ecstatic
technologies known as psychoactive
chemicals to treat people who have
severe anxiety and depression by
inducing mystical flow like experiences
of very very very intense states of flow
where people feel connected to the
infinite and in just a few sessions even
treatment-resistant PTSD can be cured
yeah so this is these are the
pharmacology elements of flow states
that are important to consider so again
this is one way to address the human
conundrum consciousness is key
consciousness can be mediated we can
take a kind of knobs and levers approach
to DJ
the theater in our mind the
reverse-engineering ourself systems to
turn ourselves from leaky buckets into
chalices and fill the hole by hacking
flow so please let's play the flow video
people talk about happiness certainly
the self-help section in the bookstore
is full of books telling you how to tap
into that happiness out of be happy out
of Think and Grow Rich so on and so
forth but what I think is ultimately
more interesting my friends is those
states north of happy now Jamie wheel
Steven collar are the cofounders of the
flow Genome Project and the flow Genome
Project aims to deconstruct the elusive
and mystical flow state now in the field
of positive psychology a flow state is a
state of consciousness in which you feel
your best and you perform your best
think of the athlete in the zone think
of the jazz musician is the pocket think
of the surfer catching that perfect wave
and these states of consciousness in
which you feel your best and you perform
your best are characterized by the
acronym skirt which stands for
selflessness the self vanishes
timelessness your sense of time dilates
and dissipates effortlessness the
just kind of flows magically and
information richness there's this
feeling of a high-res download of
realization and possibility that seems
to kind of emerge from the world around
you so again selflessness timelessness
effortlessness and information richness
it's kind of like high-definition
reality and slow low and these states of
consciousness have always been elusive
they're kind of like quasi mystical
states of ecstasy says the Greeks
described them and so Jamie Weil and
Stephen Collins new book stealing fire
eluding of course to Prometheus and
stole fire from the gods is about the
fact that finally for the first time in
history ecstatic is understandable it's
fast this is reproducible flow can be
had on tap ask not what the world needs
ask instead what makes you come alive
because what the world
more people who have come alive and this
book stealing fire is gonna bring that
to you folks I'm very excited I love
Jamie wheel and Steven caller flow
Genome Project mystical States on tap
for everyone let's democratize nirvana
let's democratize ecstatic and let's
upgrade you guys they've done all these
interesting studies of like when you
click with somebody either romantically
or platonically but when you feel that
sense of like oh I connect with this
person
that's called brain coupling and they've
done fMRI scans on people's brains and
they found out that our brains actually
do become synchronized like theta states
match the theta States or the beta
States men commit like literally the
frequencies of the brain start to mirror
each other and this is happening
wirelessly which is kind of amazing that
that mirroring can take place but here's
the thing it doesn't just happen
one-to-one with a person it can happen
one-to-many
it can happen from the screen so
literally if a video resonates if you
become immersed if you get sucked in by
a piece of content by a movie then
you're entrained with that person as
well so that's kind of amazing because
you know it shows that we communicate in
ways that are just that are beyond
language that we're literally entrained
together and and by the way in stealing
fire they talk about what they call the
altered States economy the trillion
dollars a year that we spend to get out
of our heads and that includes of course
vacations and adventures and toys and
whatever but it also includes watching
other people do crazy [ __ ] because we
mirror those people and we get off on it
biochemically as well can be like
watching an Olympian you know gymnasts
do some insane [ __ ] like we're also by
becoming in train with that person we're
getting in an altered state just by
witnessing it which is kind of amazing
so that's flow that's solution number
one to the human commander and what to
do with the time that's given to us what
to do with the space at our disposal
it's like be super creative let's
overcome our boundaries let's hack break
in flow then of course you know I have
to mention it because it's a bumper
sticker
what about passion find your passion
and I think is about you know ever make
obviously I'm passionate about my videos
you guys are passionate people you're
here blowing your own minds like it's
all good we're all passionate people
the problem is when that idea of like
find your passion gets like repeated
incessantly it starts to like lose its
power because it just kind of physical
find your passion what if I know about
that and and Steven Kotler who's the
buddy Mike here in this article in
Forbes that when I read it I was like
holy [ __ ] finally like a Venn diagram a
to-do list that like he reversed
engineered the passion equation so that
it doesn't become this like intimidating
press prospect find your passion almost
kids are like find your passion I don't
know what my passion is you know who is
it okay start with this are you curious
right something you're not passionate
you know I think it was Elizabeth
Gilbert from Eat Pray Love talks about
this all the time she's intimidated by
passion but curiosity she can do I agree
with that
okay so curious I mean curious just
means if that is holding your attention
more than that
you're curious about that I mean that's
a lot easier to identify and so he
suggests making a list of let's say 10
to 15 things that you're curious about
right the prospect of passion is scary
at least make a list of things you're
curious about and then he says look a
bit closer and where are the things that
you're curious about overlap so he talks
about like the Venn diagram idea right
and it's interesting because if multiple
curiosities let's say 3 to 5 out of
those 15 actually overlap he says the
key is that there's neurobiology
happening there because you have
multiple intersecting curiosities which
means it's creating a lot of excitement
and activity there and so he says follow
that like a compass you know you don't
need a map just follow that like a
compass and that really resonated with
me because that's like an easily
identifiable like exercise yeah
and I'm hardly like the kind of person
that gets up on stage and walks people
through exercises and I'm like kind of
cringed when it comes to those things
but this one in particular I think is
worth remembering because it's
very efficient five-step process
to seeing at the very least where your
brain is responding to and where those
curiosities intersect at least leads the
way points the way and so I'm repeating
myself a little bit but I think this is
kind of one of those takeaway messages
so this next video is precisely about
that it's about the passion equation
please show the next video so there was
a wonderful article by Steven Kotler
published in Forbes about how to find
your passion it's a question we ask
ourselves every single day we've all
been told that a life of passion is a
life that means something but how do we
identify our passions it's not always
easy so one of the things that Steven
Kotler breaks down is that he says that
passion essentially exists in the
intersection between multiple things
that you're curious about so he says the
first thing you should do if you want to
identify your passion is to make a list
of all the things that you're curious
about all the things that you wonder
about be as specific as you can and then
create kind of a Venn diagram and try to
figure out where the things that you're
curious about three or more intersect
and that's the sweet spot that's where
there is energy that's where there is
dopamine and neurobiology multiple
streams of curiosity intersect at a
space called passion right and then once
you've identified your passion then you
can figure out how to turn that passion
into a purpose turn that passion into a
purpose make a list of 15 things in the
world 15 challenges you'd like to see
solved and then figure out which one of
those challenges can be served by your
path
so then you see curiosity leads to
passion multiple streams of curiosity
leads to passion identifying problems in
the world that can be served by your
passion leads to purpose and then my
friends you've impregnated your life
with a sense of significance with a
sense of meaning and then you can go
forth my brothers you can go forth
I thought it was a great article take
note Steven Cutler's work flow Genome
Project how to find your passion it's
funny like you could pretty much count
on people responding to things regarding
flow and passion because even if it's
not something that you have every day in
your life people have had it enough
they've had a glimpse they know what at
one time when they were in flow they're
like you know or they remember at one
time in their life being really driven
to something being really passionate
about something where it wasn't about
the money and it wasn't about the status
and it wasn't about the ego but it was
about something inside of you that came
alive right and it's like that line that
says that's not what the world needs ask
instead of what makes you come alive
because what the world needs is more
people who have come alive awaken the
minds attention from the lethargy of
custom and the film of familiarity and
redirected towards the wonders of
existence and so that's actually the
next topic you know I've walked you
through flow and passion and now now
we're gonna get weird because now we're
going into action
altered states of consciousness with
like a capital C the ital is a ssin of
perception right the virginal noticing
of the sense8 world so I call my videos
shots of awe Carl Sagan famously wrote
the book contact and you guys remember
contact the movie with Jodie Foster yeah
and he described the Jodie Foster
character in the novel and then on the
movie as a wonder junkie and that's a
very powerful phrase like a wonder
junkie like somebody who's like addicted
to cosmic Wonder somebody who gazes upon
the Kosmos and Basques in wonderment
drunk on Wonder and and I identify with
this feeling very very strongly and I
trying to figure out like how in the
freakin hell do I make myself feel that
way on tap because I'm also very
familiar with tedium with the banality
z' of the
day right Walker Percy says the search
is what anyone would undertake if they
were not sunk in the everydayness of
their own lives to become aware of the
possibility of the search is to be on to
something and not to beyond to something
is to be in despair I think we all know
that feeling
so so I start thinking you know my mom
used to have all these bumper stickers
on the wall and all these quotes written
on the wall of the classroom and they
were great now there was like that Blake
one that says to see the world in a
grain of sand and heaven in a wild
flower hold infinity in the palm of your
hand and eternity in an hour right I
became fascinated by the Romantic poets
because it seemed to me that what they
were doing is they were inducing
frenzied states of consciousness they
were inducing rhapsodic states of being
and then they were transcribing them so
they were their quotes their words
became evidence of a transcendent realm
of a Platonic ideal and Michael Pollan
who you probably know is a wonderful
author he wrote a book called the botany
of desire and he had a chapter in that
book about cannabis and of course
marijuana has become legal now in
California so it's not really that
controversial to talk about the fact
that cannabis has a unique capacity to
focus attention in the here and now
Michael Pollan describes it as a
virginal noticing of the sense8 world
right that moves us beyond the bin bears
and done that of the adult mind there
right and instead towards a childlike
noticing of the world after all what is
banality and boredom except techniques
that the educated mind employs against
experience so that it can get through
the day without being continually
exhaustingly astonished we put filters
on top of our perceptions so that we're
not overwhelmed right but once in a
while we want to cleanse those doors of
perception maybe not all the time we got
to be able to let cross the street
without getting run over but we've got
to create spaces for contemplative
practices that cleanse our lenses
perception because we have these lenses
and we see with our lenses and we see
through our lenses but we don't always
see the lenses themselves and so in
order to sometimes get out of ourselves
and see those lenses and move those
lenses aside and experience what Timothy
Leary calls experiencing afresh the
hardly bearable ecstasy of direct
experience exploding on our nerve
endings like that's what we want
exhilarating neuro storms of intense
intellectual pleasure and it all begins
and ends with attention so you can go
back to mindfulness or whatever but
Charles Darwin wrote that attention if
sudden and close graduates into surprise
and this into astonishment and this into
stupefied amazement which is like an
orgiastic state of grace so it's all
about attention but that's really
[ __ ] hard today we have an infinite
amount of signals competing for our
attention we live in a fragmented age
where we pretend to be multitaskers when
we know from neuroscience that
multitasking is actually impossible so
all that you actually do is move switch
rapidly between tasks and do perform
worse in multiple tasks but the problem
with that is that the sort of the price
of efficiency is that we're less present
and we're less able to experience the
deep focused immersive attention that
can induce that state of grace and
astonishment I think it was Henry Miller
who said even a blade of grass if you
give it your full attention if you look
at it through a microscope it is a
cosmos right but to have the to
luxuriate in marveling at a blade of
grass isn't deficient look get back to
work or anyone's staring at the grass
like a [ __ ]
but like we need that you know we want
to we want to marvel we want to wonder
not even a blade of grass how about that
but the freaking universe right I
personally I love going to Tulum because
there's no light pollution there you can
walk on the beach you can actually see
all the stars and then it's like you
reminded that you're like hanging off a
planet and there's this like ineffable
like you know contemplating space and
time and a scale just shy of the
infinite and you're like oh my god it's
a rasa Anderson as his name he wrote an
article about the Hubble Space Telescope
you guys know the Hubble Space Telescope
it's like literally a telescope that we
put into orbit okay and it's like okay
just remember like human beings right
the naked animals that crawl the surface
of the earth the monkeys without hair we
put in goddamn optic nerve in orbit that
allows us to mainline space and time
through the optic nerve and he talks
about how the images that the Hubble
took of the Deep Field photograph that's
when it took a picture of like a little
piece of like nothing you know away from
the stars like it was a dark nothing and
then they processed that and it was like
galaxy galaxies upon galaxies in a
little smidge of dark it so he said that
gazing upon the Deep Field was nothing
less than an ontological awakening a
forceful reckoning with what is oh [ __ ]
he says through the sheer aesthetic
force of its discoveries the Hubble
distilled the complex abstractions of
astrophysics into singular expressions
of color and light vindicating Keith's
famous couplets beauty is truth truth is
beauty how's that for fixing the
existential bummer right so this next
video attempts to somehow transmute and
induce what that rhapsodic state of
heightened attention feels like when you
mediate and steward the contents of
consciousness when you
present in a way that you're living
psychedelically and tapping into a
continuous state of understanding let's
show the next video please
Terence Mckenna used to say that living
psychedelically requires tapping into a
continuous state of understanding right
he talks about the power of remediating
attention which echoes Darwin's ideas
that attention if sudden and close we
graduated to surprise and this into
Spanish meant and this into stupefied
amazement and remembers
becomes an infinitely magnificent world
in itself right so if we are able to
harness to leverage to italicize to
focus our attention everything becomes
miraculous in fact if the doors of
perception were cleansed as Aldous
Huxley says everything would appeared to
us how it actually is
right but of course this gets in the way
of functioning in the war
and rapidly switching between tasks as
we decide when the light is red when the
light
Clyde to where to go with the text back
there's an infinite amount of signals
competing for our attention
very rarely do we get to be in a state
of spontaneous flow in the here-and-now
reacting dynamically to stimuli in a way
that feels magical right the the Indian
mystic ninja I got that I used to say
the other world is this world right Lee
seed Yeats used to say the world is full
of magic Singh is patiently waiting for
our senses to grow sharper so perhaps
new emerging technologies artificially
intelligent algorithms can be a humanist
for us to offload cognition offload
learning tasks to the machines and free
us into living in spaces and places of
imagination Terence Mckenna says the
future of humanity is us moving into the
imagination to fully turn our minds
inside out and inhabit spaces that are
linguistic constructs spaces built and
shaped by mind and thoughts and
intentionality these are not virtual
realities these are the realities of the
virtual your boat gently down the stream
merrily merrily merrily merrily life is
but a dream that video was really fun to
make and you know when I was quoting
Terence Mckenna Terence Mckenna is a
psychedelic philosopher who like back in
the 80s and 90s was talking about
virtual reality so really he was a cyber
Delic philosopher cyber Daleks merges
cybernetics and psychedelic and it's
this idea that technology is the
literalization of our psychedelic dreams
of manifesting mind in the world and so
in talking about us moving into the
imagination you know it sounds like a
sci-fi orgy istic dream except that now
that conversation is becoming ever more
real the rapidly evolving space of
virtual realities probably going to be
where we're gonna spend more and more of
our mind time and by the way this is not
all bad so there's a guy called eval
Harari who wrote a book called sapiens
you've probably heard of it and his new
book called day
is all about future technologies and how
he say we're gonna engender a kind of
godhood for ourselves but he wrote an
article in The Guardian that was talking
about how to create meaning in a world
without work because one of the fears of
our rapidly changing technological
landscape and one of the sources of our
anxiety besides of course the
existential angst is you know a lot of
us fill our days with work and busyness
you know and so with more of our jobs
get taken over by the machines it's not
just oh how am I gonna feed myself but
it's also how am I gonna fill the
emptiness and the void you know not all
of us are philosophically inclined some
of us just want like a steady
distraction and what he says which is
really interesting is he says look we're
probably gonna move into virtual
realities and the AI is and the advances
in biotechnology and genetics are
probably gonna lead us into a world of
abundance we're probably gonna have
universal basic income we already have
the technology to take care of everyone
on the planet as soon as we get our act
together we'll apply that capacity so
well we'll be fed you know we'll be
sheltered like that won't be an issue
the issue will be how do we feel
significant in the world and so he says
we're gonna live in virtual realities
and so people are that's so artificial
and fake first of all these virtual
reality environments are gonna be
indistinguishable from this world I mean
it'll be like the matrix but not a
prison it'll be liberation and I'll tell
you why we already have virtual
realities by consensus and agreement
they become real so one virtual reality
is your name there's nothing objective
in the world that says that your name is
your name that's a completely virtual
reality but you're invested in and
you're so invested in it that it bleeds
into the real geography like the lines
in separate countries it's another
virtual reality religion is another
virtual reality right it has rules you
score points and then you get to the
next level
these are all virtual realities but the
thing is yes yes but they don't lack
reality because there are real patterns
of information just like dreams don't
lack reality there are real patterns of
information once you invest yourself
completely in a virtual reality right in
a reality tunnel that you know the
suspension of disbelief as they call it
it's like when you're watching a movie
you know it's movie you still experience
it vicariously through the characters
mirror and you model the characters you
experience a completely real experience
under imaginary circumstances when you
watch a film it's like a living
programmatic dream space I mean that
already exists so there's nothing fake
about virtual reality we have them all
the time we live inside of them all the
time the difference is that in this
future when we don't have to work
anymore
the idea being we're gonna plug into
like ready player one type worlds like
fully immersive virtual worlds where
each of us will be gods
in the Kosmos of our imagination and how
this will change human intimacy right is
where it gets really exciting so Terence
Mckenna will say something like you know
right now if I want to be intimate with
you you know I tell you that I love you
and maybe we get naked and we'll put a
nice music on we look into each other's
eyes and we try to merge right like it's
kind of awkward you know skin you can't
like get inside the other person fully
right he says okay and so maybe you
bring them into your room you showed me
books you showed me your paintings you
sing them a song like these are ways of
trying to communicate the contents of
our minds to one another to create inter
subjective spaces so he says in the
future you'll be able to invite somebody
into your universe not just your room
not just your book but inside your mind
come visit my mind and so the new forms
of inter subjective intimacy between
people will be able fidelity that we
cannot even begin to imagine I mean
it'll be more probably more beautiful
and rhapsodic than the greatest painting
you've ever experienced that gives you
an insight into that artists mind or the
greatest film you've ever seen that
gives you an insight into that directors
genius I mean we'll all be truly capable
of creating spaces to share with one
another of a fidelity that we can
begin to imagine so that's just a side
note about my mention of VR switching
gears now I want to talk about mystical
experiences because it's the fourth one
right after flow and after passion and
after learning to control attention
there's you know some traumas that need
a bigger intervention some existential
conundrums that need a bigger jolt into
into the stomach so right now there's
these interesting studies happening at
Johns Hopkins University and they're
basically taking people who have cancer
diagnosis and who have developed what's
called end of life anxiety and by the
way who [ __ ] wouldn't right I've just
been told by a doctor that you're gonna
die sooner than you thought because you
have cells that have rebelled and
metastasized in your body I mean it's
who wouldn't develop end-of-life anxiety
right so they take these people and they
bring them into a comfortable living
room with a couple of psychologists and
guides and they give them psilocybin
which is the active ingredient in magic
mushrooms and magic mushrooms imagine a
lot of free thinkers in this room magic
mush magic mushrooms have been used for
thousands of years in sacramental and
ritualistic contexts because in a way
they're the most active placebos in the
world right like if you create a space
that feels sort of sacred and you bring
that kind of intention into the room and
then you take that trust me you will get
what you look for but it turns out that
putting these people in these controlled
environments with two psychologists and
guides walking them through what to
expect has a reliable record now of
inducing mystical experiences and again
a mystical experience it's like inverse
PTSD so what's interesting about it is
it's characterized by feelings of
ineffability it's an experience of such
radiance that you can't put it into
language or you feel like language
doesn't do it justice there's a feeling
of transcendence of time and space
there's a feeling of connection among
all things so the boundaries between
self and world
dissipate there's a sense of cosmic mood
lifting there's a sense of grace it was
the psychologist William James I think
who identified all of the
characteristics of a mystical experience
if it ticks all the boxes it's a
mystical experience and as it turns out
when they administer the psilocybin with
people who with end of life in xiety
those that had a full-fledged mystical
experience that ticked all the boxes so
this one you know the qualitative
experience and not just the drug does
fixes this it's the drug in combination
with the subjective experience they no
longer have fear of death they are cured
of their end-of-life anxiety they are at
peace with the infinite they are one
with the cosmos you know they went to
God just to see and they came back
smiling right and so I was like okay
well wow what does it feel like to have
a mystical experience you know what is
it like to have your perceptual models
of reality defragmented and what does it
feel like to be pummeled against into
infinity like people say it's ineffable
you can't put it into words that was
what I do you know people sometimes say
don't try to like I want my interest in
ultimately is in clothing the numinous I
want to like sort of wrap my head and
heart around something an experience for
me is not real unless I can describe it
I require consensus and in order to you
to know what I know or do you to feel
what I feel I have to communicate it in
a way that meets my criteria for
effectivity and knowing okay yeah I made
you feel exactly what I wanted you to
feel and so I decided let's do a video
about mystical experiences and and we
use this also to raise money for an
organization that's helping fund these
studies to help suffering Souls address
their ills
let's show the mystical experience
throughout much of human history sages
have spoken about the mystical
experience perhaps the most meaningful
experience that human beings are capable
of having a mystical experience is an
encounter with the transcendent right
it's an encounter with the numinous when
Otto rank described as the mysterium
tremendum gave a solution of reality
when the doors of perception are
cleansed and the mystical experience has
some characteristics some persistent
hallmarks that always show up no matter
the culture or worldview and belief
system of whoever is having it so there
are these common attributes that show up
with mystical experiences they are the
following the mystical experience is
characterized by feelings of cosmic
unity feelings of oneness with endless
feelings of interconnection a mystical
experience is characterized by feelings
of transcendence of time and space the
mind freed from the shackles of the
Eagle freed from the constraints of time
and space the mystical experience is
characterized by positive
right a feeling of bliss a feeling of
ecstasy a feeling of gratitude right
you were magic the mystical experience
is characterized by feelings of the sea
of connecting with the divine the
mystical experience is characterized by
enough ability a feeling that you can't
quite put it into words and it's an
experience beyond language you can't
clothe it with language the mystical
experience is characterized by feelings
of paradoxically feelings where you can
hold multiple perspectives in mind at
once where contradictions are wreaking
desire where you can conceive of
opposites and somehow hold them in mind
at once
bicycle experience is characterized by
its 2d game quality it's something
converge to dissolve just as quickly
it's it's a finite experience a mystical
experience is characterized by feelings
of transformative change that are
lasting so even though it's a temporary
experience a person is forever
transformed new perspectives are
includes new visionary understanding is
felt and and so a person is forever made
better person feels like they have seen
the light whereas once we were blind now
we can see and finally a mystical
experience leaves us with a quality of
analytic flavor right there's this sense
that what we're seeing and what was
understood and what was felt
has some deeper veracity than everyday
reality has some kind of deeper meaning
beyond our normal literal grid and
there's a sense that there is ultimate
truth and ultimate meaning to what was
apprehended and this lasts indefinitely
so these are the hallmarks of a mystical
experience something that as human
beings we should all aim to encounter at
least once in our lives because as David
Foster Wallace wrote the alternative is
unconsciousness the default setting the
rat-race
the constant nonsense
add and lost some infinity
[Music]
thank you so if you probably noticed I
quote a lot of people when I talk like a
[ __ ] dictionary of quotes and I think
the reason for that to me is very clear
it goes back to a desire for explaining
things for clothing the transcendence
for putting a blanket over it or
encapsulating ineffability that's like
how I get off to be honest no no it
really is like I literally mind gasm
when I effectively am able to create a
container for ineffability right for
that infinite thing David Foster Wallace
wrote about right because again the
alternative is unconsciousness the
default setting the rat-race
the constant gnawing sense and it is
gnawing eating at you inside the
constant gnawing sense of having had and
lost some infinite thing what is this
infinite thing this infinite thing is
all psychologists out of Stanford
Berkeley other places describe aw as an
experience of such a perceptual
expansion all right perceptual expansion
that your mental models of the world
because that's what our brains do
they're predicting machines they make
models of the world they make inferences
about reality that's how we work our
mental models of the world have to react
AMA date themselves right rias to take
in to assimilate what has just
transpired and that can be seen the
Grand Canyon for the first time
planet Earth well stoned out of your
mind the birth of a child sees some of
the sculptures at dawn like you know
sometimes watching airplanes taking off
just so by having to accommodate
ourselves to what we're seeing right we
experience this exhilaration
we're cracked open and the light gets in
it's also called Opie aided adjacency
and as it turns out these trends for
this transitory enchanted moment we hold
our breath as that scott Fitzgerald said
compelled into an aesthetic
contemplation face to face with
something can measure it to our capacity
for wonder all right feels really good
flow Barre said human speech is but a
crack kettle on which we tap crude
rhythms while we long to make music that
will melt the stars so pretty much every
video is an attempt to give you a little
taste little micro dose but I recently
decided you know what I'm just going to
put on the screen those images that have
done it to me
so I decided to pay homage homage to
thank you to those filmmakers that are
the original gods as far as I'm
concerned right cinema is truth 24 times
per second the temple of the movie
theater as far as I'm concerned I don't
like the movie theaters where they give
you food and this and that you're not
you're [ __ ] living then you're in
church come and sit in the darkness
turn off your [ __ ] phone and let the
light come in but anyway
so I wanted I wanted to get to honor
those that have created that have burned
the images on my retina that have shown
me the light that have shown me what aw
is that have shown me that infinite
thing that have made me bow down before
the cinema gods particularly I mean I
love romantic films too don't get me
wrong I'm gonna cry
but metaphysical science fiction right
we're talking like 2001 a Space Odyssey
we're talking inception give a little
interstellar maybe Danny Boyle's
sunshine there's there's a bunch we need
more of these kinds of films for me they
are they are Godhead and so so I'm
really excited about this next video in
honor of those movies and those musical
scores
that's so effectively jolt us out of our
stupor and show us the divine so please
show the last video and make sure it's
nice and loud so this is a score from
the movie sunshine directed by Danny
Boyle screenplay by Alex garland a film
that portrays a mission to reignite the
Sun the Sun is dying and humanity's last
hope is a ship that's gonna deploy ten
thousand nuclear bombs to reignite the
Sun I mean what a plot and the music the
score perhaps more than anything else is
the soul of the film for it manages to
render an ineffable feeling
which is to come face to face with God
himself right all the human stories all
the religious myths all the origin tales
of the Son of God so to speak well
Mercker referred to the son an ancient
pagan religions the son was God all of
life comes from it it is you know the
the the firt the atoms that were cooked
in the furnaces of dying stars that
created everything it's open for human
beings to come face to face with that in
the observation deck in the moving
sunshine impregnates to plot with a
metaphysical and religious flavor and
tone you can't help but get caught up in
larger questions about what it means to
be sentient questions about the human
spirit questions about our capacity to
come together and overcome the greatest
hurdles
[Music]
only dream I ever had is the surface of
the Sun this is one of the characters
has the incandescent lightbulb of
creation burns itself in their retina
metaphysical science fiction films blend
religion and science and psyche to
create a psychedelic experience that
cracks us open and lets in the light and
the divine Dreamweavers that make these
films that compose these scores that
direct these screenplays the cards on
the screen that beckon the choice
[Music]
what might be
we know what we are said Shakespeare we
know not who we might be
just sit with that for a moment ah
percussion kicks in intensity levels
rise emotion nears climax
you spill over you overflow you mind
gasm
you went to God just to see and you were
looking at me
[Music]
the raptures radiates
[Applause]
seeing the songs that orchestrate the
universe
final
gasps
[Music]